c'est l'hypothèse des défenseurs de
julian assange la cia aurait projeté une
éventuelle opération pour kidnapper
voire assassiner le journaliste
australien alors qu'il était retranché
dans l'ambassade d'équateur un projet
confirmé ce week-end par trois
journalistes dans une enquête publiée
sur yahoo news arrêter ce que vous êtes
en train de faire et lisez ceci la cia a
élaboré des plans pour tuer ou kidnappés
un journaliste maintes fois primées dont
il n'aimait pas le travail avant de
l'accuser d'un crime la faire contre
julian assange doit être abandonnée et
condamné les trois journalistes ont
interrogé pas moins de trente anciens
officiels du renseignement américain
selon eux cette en 2017 alors que julian
assange entamait sa cinquième année
confinée dans l'ambassade d'équateur que
la cia aurait envisagé l'opération la
cia aurait fomenté l'enlèvement du
fondateur de wikileaks suscitant un
débat houleux parmi les responsables de
l'administration trump sur la légalité
et la faisabilité d'une telle opération
certains hauts responsables de la cia et
de l'administration trump ou même
discuté du meurtre d'assange allant
jusqu'à demander des ébauches ou des
options sur la façon de l'assassiner des
discussions sur l'enlèvement ou le
meurtre d'assange ont eu lieu au plus
haut niveau de l'administration de
trains ajoute l'inde et ancien haut
responsable du contre-espionnage il ne
semblait pas y avoir de limites des
pistes qui seront finalement abandonnée
au profit je cite d'une approche basée
sur les tribunaux la cia ainsi que
l'ancien secrétaire d'état mais qu on
paie aux mises en cause dans cette
enquête n'ont pas souhaité répondre aux
journalistes de son côté l'avocat de
julian assange s'est dit choqué et
espère que cette enquête jouera un rôle
dans la décision de la justice
britannique d'extrader ou non julian
assange vers les etats unis en tant que
citoyen américain je trouve absolument
scandaleux que notre gouvernement
envisage d'en lever ou d' assassiner
quelqu'un sans aucune procédure
judiciaire
simplement parce qu'il a publié des
informations avérées j'ai espoir et
j'attends des tribunaux britanniques
qu'ils prennent en compte ces
informations dans leur décision de ne
pas extrader julian assange dans les
états unis julian assange est lui
toujours en détention provisoire à
londres en attendant la fin de la
procédure d'extradition à son encontre
il risque aux états unis 175 ans de
prison